NATO's Chief says Ukraine is gradually
making progress in its counter-offensive
against Russian forces Jen stoltenberg
met with President Vladimir zielinski
during a surprise trip to Kiev in a
joint press conference stoltenberg
stressed that members of the military
Alliance would keep providing Ukraine
with ammunition
today your forces are moving forward
they face Fierce fighting but they are
gradually gaining ground
every meter
that Ukrainian forces regains
is a meter that Russia loses
stark contrast
ukrainians are fighting for their
families their future their freedom
Moscow is fighting for Imperial
delusions
Ravi is alive for us in cave and uh I
guess a show of support there from
stoltenberg what else did he have to say
on this visit
that's exactly right it was an
unannounced visit comes on the same day
as a visit by the defense Ministers of
UK and France so certainly an important
day for the government here in Kiev
anytime such high profile visits happen
something president zielinski puts
forward to everyone he talks to is the
need for air defenses that Ukraine needs
better air defenses and that's something
he raised with stoltenberg saying that
ahead of the winter Ukraine needs air
defenses to protect not just its cities
but key power infrastructure if you
remember last year Ukraine's energy
infrastructure was the target across the
country for sustained Russian attacks
during the winter months so in
preparation for the winter he renewed
that call for better air defenses from
the Allies that is not something he's
going to get yet but what he did get
were kind words from stoltenberg as well
as a great deal of commitment uh
Financial commitment to restoring
Ukraine's ammunition stocks uh Stilton
brick said NATO and Ukraine have never
been closer and to make that point
committed 2.5 more than 2.5 billion
dollars worth of key ammunition for
tanks for a long-range artillery like
Howitzer shells that would be used uh to
the tune of per shell we're looking at
around 500 to 150 000 in cost depending
on the type of shells you're talking
about and 2.5 billion dollars buys
Ukraine a great deal of ammunition which
buys them more time in this fight
something that is very important in this
visit stoltenberg's words the meetings
with zelinski a kind of recognition that
they are in this for the Long Haul
zielinski has been saying for several
weeks that this will be a long War there
have been predictions by analysts that
it'll go on well past 2024 well past
2025 and this commitment of admonition
seemingly underlining that reality at
the same time we've seen this week
Russia announce a massive height in its
military spending going forward taken
together this is a clear signal to
Ukrainian people as well as to the
people from the countries that are
supporting Ukraine in this war that is
likely to go on much longer than anyone
expected okay thank you so much for that
sign that design best Ravi for us in
cave